today we're going to be talking about
everything that happens off of YouTube I
titled this presentation building your
back end turning a casual viewer into
raving fans today we're going to be
going through building a better lead
magnet I've been in the internet
marketing world as well as like playing
around on the internet for at least 10
years this landing page is one of the
very first landing pages that I ever
opted into I have a folder on my desktop
of all the lead magnets it's like a lead
magnet folder like whenever I opt into
something that piques my interest that I
want to pay attention to I put it into
this folder and this is one of the first
and right when I graduated from college
I was really interested in just figuring
out the money game and I ended up buying
ah gosh probably between 10 and 15
different books in the money sphere and
I will teach you to be rich ramit
statist book
um was one of the first ones that I
bought and I really got into his world
just because he spoke a lot to kind of
my demographic of like people were just
graduating who didn't want to over
complicate money and it was to me he
just really spoke to me as far as uh how
he positioned things and uh to be to be
quite honest uh I stumbled upon him as a
function of uh the first ever personal
development book was with uh Tim Ferriss
and he had done an interview
specifically with ramit and that was
kind of how I got into ramit's world but
this lead magnet was really interesting
to me because I think this lead magnet
has a lot of characteristics that a lot
of times uh as entrepreneurs we tend to
overlook
um a lot of times with lead magnets we
kind of default to I'm gonna build uh
you know a 40 to 50 page book uh I want
that to be my lead magnet something
that's a little bit more meaty and
tangible whereas uh this lead magnet I
think the the beauty of it is its own
Simplicity and what I mean by that is it
has a very simple promise by downloading
this lead magnet you're going to save
between a few hundred dollars and a
thousand dollars and about a 30 minute
phone call which is which is like a
pretty like oh
30 minutes I got 30 minutes I can saving
a thousand bucks that sounds really
great
what's what was great about this is the
the PDF was only one or two pages and
all it was is here's what you're gonna
do you're gonna call up your service for
your your internet service provider and
you're going to specifically ask them to
talk to a a retention specialist so I.E
you're you're thinking about leaving and
you know you you want to you want to
talk to somebody who is there
specifically to keep you as a customer
and you're going to explain to them that
you've been shopping around you you know
you maybe are off of the uh the one or
two year annual discount and you're you
know you notice that uh competitor is
going to give you a better price
and lo and behold after having a 10-15
minute conversation my bill went from 75
a month down to 30.
same internet speed like nothing changed
I just saved money
and it was it was one of those really
fast you know it's like
you go through that experience and it's
like wow
I opted in for this thing I consumed the
activity it only took a few minutes and
I got the result that I was promised
for me that is what that is kind of what
led me to going deeper and really
ingraining myself into like everything
that was ramit seti at the time
and I I've literally been on his list
since 2013. at this point I think I've
bought probably two or three different
programs uh from him I believe that a
lot of times we over complicate what a
lead magnet is
and I I wanted to kind of boil Down lead
magnets into a very simplistic framework
so the the first thing that needs to
happen for a lead magnet is we need to
make it easy to consume at the end of
the day we all have we all have you know
the same 24 hours in the day but what we
need to do is we need to figure out how
can we make this as consumable as
possible so that when somebody opts in
they can quickly go through the material
and really understand what it is what
the result that we're trying to give
them and ultimately help them get that
as quickly as possible if you think
about like the customer journey of an
individual coming through uh your
business you know whether you're talking
about
um you know whether you're coaching them
through a process or uh ultimately you
know teaching them how to negotiate
better or things like that
you really need to figure out like what
is the thing that is going to really get
them ingrained in what I have to say as
well as give them that quick win when we
can give them that quick win it creates
that connection of oh this person is
actually here to help me and a lot of
times it will get people to start asking
the question like if this is the free
stuff that they give I wonder what the
paid stuff looks like
ultimately that's our goal is how can we
really get them ingrained in what we
have to offer because let's be honest we
all we all want to have impact and and
make a difference in other people's
lives and I think a lot of times uh we
think that it has to be this big
grandiose thing but sometimes the small
wins are actually what makes the biggest
impact
so some really easy ways to make things
that are very consumable obviously
videos are are pretty good
um I would not recommend doing like full
long hour you know some people will do a
lead magnet as like a webinar like an
hour-long webinar
um at least for me when I consume
something
I try I try to consume something in a
pretty short period of time I don't want
to wait I don't want to have to go
through an hour-long presentation it's
like give me the highlights so how do I
how do I create a short video or a
checklist or something simple that can
ultimately uh get the result that you're
looking to give that person so just a
couple of examples of some things that
meet this criteria so specifically we
had ramit's example of you know as a
function of that 30 minute phone call
I saved 35 a month which is 360 a year
or 300 and actually it's like 400 bucks
um another another example that I
thought was a really good one was uh it
was a seven day challenge that Pat Flynn
did
um he did get your first 100 emails in
seven days
now what was interesting about his
challenge is is he Incorporated a lot of
different mechanics on the back end so
you opted in uh you opted into the
challenge you got your first welcome
email and the way that it worked is uh
you ultimately got into a Facebook group
and then every day in that Facebook
group
he would post an activity for the day
basically
um the idea was each activity should
take no more than 10 to 15 minutes to
complete
and it systematically walked you through
here is you know here are the steps you
need to take in order to get those first
hundred emails so obviously like day one
was setting up uh it actually wasn't
what you would think it was it most
people would say oh I need to get them
to get an email autoresponder and he's
like no no no no don't worry about the
email autoresponder what you're gonna do
is you're going to go through your phone
and you're gonna find 10 people in your
phone of who would be interested in the
things that you talk about and you're
simply going to send them a text
hey I would love to send you an email
I'm I'm forming this newsletter I just
want to add value to people
send the text so he he gave you a couple
of scripts on what you could send out
and like I said in each and every day he
had a new task similar to that
and his recommendation was don't over
complicate it don't feel like you need
to go get an autoresponder just do it
with your email use your personal email
if you feel bad about sending out your
personal email you know make sure you
BCC everybody and just start your
newsletter that way it's just how do I
get you to take the steps to like do the
action
so I'm going to talk about how can you
use retargeting and this is where a lot
of people
um mess up again when they're creating
their ad strategies so we we hopefully
know retargeting from our other
marketing efforts right somebody's hit
our landing page and then we hit them
with a Facebook ad or a YouTube ad they
you know based off them their cookie of
being on our page now we can retarget
them as much as possible we can do that
in YouTube as well for people who have
viewed a video but have not subscribed
to the channel
so often one of the biggest ways to win
in the short term is you create an ad
group
of people who have viewed videos on your
channel and you can go up to 540 days of
data
they viewed a video but they have not
subscribed yet to the channel
if they've already subscribed we don't
want to show them yeah they're already
our subscriber right unless we just care
about views we want to try to convert
people
so the next set of settings when you're
creating the campaign we've got
demographics this one really depends on
how much you know your demographics if
you know that you sell to middle-aged
women great you put that in there if you
know that you sell the teenage men great
you put that in there otherwise leave it
open and let YouTube find the best fit
for you the household income one is
interesting for buyers so if you're
selling something that's really high
ticket
you want to be targeting the upper 50 of
people for household income uh that's
again only specific you're trying to
Target buyers because if you want just
audience growth we want to Target
everybody
and then here when you're going to
audiences this is where it can start to
get fun and we'll dive in a little bit
uh on this session so you can pick who
you're going to Target
and you can pick who you're going to
exclude
so this was this this is I just went to
my channel this is my one of my sub
channels this channel has 50 something
thousand subscribers on it so I tried to
post something a little more close to
you guys
so not subscribed as 87 which is good
you want you're not subscribed to be in
the 75 to 90 range if you're talking
only to your subscribe people we've
talked about this on previous sessions
and your channel is not growing because
you're only talking to people who know
who you are so so this is this is a good
number you can check out your own
numbers to see how well you're doing but
we want to be in the 75 to 90 range
and YouTube ads currently past 28 days
makes up eight percent of my views
so suggest is number one this is where
we want to be playing always right most
of the things that we've talked about in
previous sessions have been about how do
we get more suggested views that's where
you're going to get the organic growth
uh but there is a little bit of an ad
Budget on this channel and it's driven
eight percent of the views
so I've done two different audiences so
when you're in AdWords you go to your
audience manager
and you can create different audience
lists and you know for the veterans here
you know what I'm talking about for
newbies just go to audience manager and
and go to audience list and then click
plus you sync your YouTube channels and
I'm marketing to both my main Channel as
well as my top 10 rules Channel viewers
and what it will do is create a list and
you can select how many days the default
is 30 days
I stretch it out to 540 so that's the
max so anybody who's watched a video in
the past 540 days stays on this list
so even if you're not into ads yet or
you're on the fence or you're thinking
about it it's worth just setting up this
audience because it starts tracking from
the day you set it up
so if I set it up today it gives me 30
days back plus everything forward
so even if you don't plan on running ads
until next year
right if you're going to plan ads in one
year from today you'll at least have a
big audience of data where if you just
set up the audience in a year
you're starting from scratch
so at the very least you want to set up
viewers and subscribers for your Channel
the subscribers are helpful because you
can exclude them but also uh if you want
to Target them with pre-roll ads so if
you have a new book to sell new course
to sell new whatever else to sell you
can Target them not only on your channel
but if they come and watch an Evan
Carmichael video they can see your
pre-roll ad before it pitching your
thing and they already know who you are
where most of the ads like hi let me
introduce myself I am this expert as
opposed to they already know who you are
they've already subscribed to your
channel those are going to be much more
effective at converting to a sale
so step one is just creating those
audience lists
for your views
okay
then we're in our YouTube ads campaign
we can see that I added these two
audiences and I exclude that people who
already subscribe to the channel
so it's going to go to the people who
have viewed my videos but are not yet
subscribed
to my channel
this is one of the cheapest most
effective ways to start getting paid
Subs because you're targeting people
who've already watched one of your
videos now maybe you don't have millions
and millions of views that's fine
you can set caps and limits on how often
the ad will show up
but now your ad is going to be showing
up no matter where they go on YouTube
right again if they're following me
subscribe to me or they're just watching
some sports or some politics or whatever
on YouTube your video will still be
showing up as a suggested video because
they've watched another one of your
videos in the past 540 days
is all this making sense am I losing
anybody any questions yeah I was shaking
heads okay
but again if if you need to pause
they're like wait I didn't understand
that slide pop it in the chat
um but we'll also get the questions soon
targeting people who've watched the
video but I'm not yet subscribed and
showing them new content I like to put
in all the videos from the channel but
you can also pick select ones if you
want
so
this has shown what's happened in the
past 30 days I mean Canada so all these
are Canadian numbers so I spent not a
ton 700 bucks so let's call it 600 us
and I got 600 subscribers so about a
dollar for a subscriber I'm targeting
the Big Four
I don't care about just getting people
from anywhere to I don't care about
their vanity numbers enough on this
channel to go after them I want people
who are in the Big Four markets that I
could potentially sell to uh so it's
costing me a dollar to get a subscriber
it's pretty good if I was if I didn't
care about where they came from that'd
be a lot a lot a lot cheaper right here
it's costing me six cents so let's call
it five cents to get a view US
that would be under a cent if I was
going International the half a cent
point seven five cents to get a view
from people who viewed already one of my
videos
so this is where we want to be paying
attention
earn subscribers
uh you can see earned views so I've
gotten 11 000 views that I paid for and
it got me 7 300 views on top of it
so I paid for these and I got these for
free
that's pretty good targeting that's
almost you know whatever we want to call
that's
65 percent of people who watch one who
watch the ad then go watch another video
on the channel
if you've seen numbers like that you've
done a good job with the targeting
and then 10 of them then roughly go on
to convert to become subscribers of the
channel
you can't optimize for this
so there's no rule that you can say
uh like sales this this is really
designed as a sales tool so it keeps
track of the click-through rate and the
cost per click and how many conversions
you get either just hitting your landing
page or hitting the hitting the
confirmation page you can tell Google
optimize for that you can't tell Google
optimize for earned subscribers
you just have to look at the report so
because it's an extra little step a lot
of people aren't doing it which creates
a lot of opportunity for you
Robert in the house for the ad video do
you always create a video as an ad or do
you promote existing videos from your
Channel the existing videos from the
channel if our goal is to convert them
to subscribers right
I've I've looked at a bunch of campaigns
where people were making videos to say
hey subscribe to my channel I'm going to
tell you how to do XYZ they make it an
ad
it just doesn't work as well as an
actual value
content
like think about what would you
subscribe to more
you know Casey hears from Jeff Jeff
Walker's team or Jeff comes on and
actually gives me value teaches me
something or Jeff comes on and says
subscribe to my channel it's gonna be
great I promise it's like people just
love the content a lot more uh you get
tested
but again you know my goal with all
these presentations to give you best
practices of what's actually working
right now so I would recommend you
actually doing
the videos on the channel either
specific videos and I'll share a screen
showing you what that looks like but
either specific videos that you want to
Target that audience or just all the
videos on your channel and let YouTube
decide which ones are having the best
impact
Jew says if you include the earned views
your effective cost per view is actually
three cents Canadian yeah if you're
doing some some quick math uh yeah
almost
right I got almost
you know maybe maybe three and a half
cents Canadian you know two and a half
cents American right so this this is
just showing you how much people
actually are are connecting to the
content that you're putting up
so this is easy to get you know 11 000
views okay great
this are people then watching another
video on your channel that depends on
how not even how good the content is
because you guys have good content I'm
assuming the content is good when we've
talked a lot about your different
channels it's more about the audience
if you're targeting 13 year olds who
love Minecraft it doesn't matter how
good content you have
they're just not going to click and
they're not going to subscribe right if
they do it's because they click the
button by accident so the target of the
audience becomes super important
so you can look at it on an ad group
level this is an ad group right just for
all of my top 10 videos and then you can
look at it on an individual video level
so what we'll do for this channel
because all of the content is pretty
much
the same it's similar
um we'll put all the videos in
and then we'll just sort by our own
subscribers and see which ones are doing
well now when it's under a hundred
subscribers gained it puts it in the
buckets
so how many did this Bruce Lee one get
us in the past 30 days you know
somewhere between 61 to 80. as this gets
over a hundred it'll show you exact
numbers
now we don't have a ton of data on
individual videos because
we max out you can have 300 videos in
one group
and we hit 300 and then we just slowly
the ones that get zero we pull out and
keep swapping new ones in so there's a
lot of data in here you can see this one
is AD number 110 ad number 104. we just
throw them all in and then let YouTube
decide to show the ones that are having
the biggest uptick
the reason why is because if if I was
picking
I wouldn't have picked any of these four
videos
you know if I was thinking okay what are
the ones I'm gonna pop off the hardest
for me on my top 10 Channel I would have
put I would have put Tony Robbins you
know I would have put Warren Buffett I
would have put Oprah Winfrey I would
have put some of the bigger names but
it's Bruce Lee the Dalai Lama
Jay-Z Michael Jordan I wouldn't have
picked these four and yet they're the
ones that are working the best
so you you could pick if you know the
targeting super well but otherwise if
it's if it's General to the category I
just throw all of them in
because they've already watched a video
on your channel now we're letting them
letting YouTube sort by whichever ones
are getting the the best results
YouTube's not going by earned
subscribers they're just basically
trying to optimize how many views you
can get for the budget so we're just
assuming that the more people view a
video the more likely they're going to
subscribe it's not
100 accurate right like this one
um
61 let's call this 70 subscribers for
for 900 views and this one got 400 views
for 10 subscribers so this one's
performing better in the past 30 days
right
um you could if you really want to go
video by video by video we just throw
them all in my assistant does it and
once we hit 300 usually once a week
she'll swap out the worst seven and then
pop seven new ones in
so for those who don't know I'm running
the show today uh let me give you a
little bit of background on me my name
is Drew Hitchcock I am in Cincinnati
Ohio I'm a part of the Evan Carmichael
team and I don't think that we've ever
really deep dived into the split testing
process so I kind of wanted to give you
guys some perspective on how I think
through this process
um as well as kind of how Evan talks or
or thinks through this process
so how many people
have got had like logged into their back
end
and found this lovely little picture of
their last video and it's showing up as
10 out of 10.
nobody
uh mine's usually like seven or eight
okay well I know whenever I see this I
get super frustrated but at the same
time it also it also creates a very
interesting opportunity for us because
now this is something that we can go
back on the back end and actually fix
because
we have the ability to test which is
great and the reason why this is
important is because at the end of the
day if we can get these underperforming
videos to perform better over time we
can actually really move the needle for
our channels in in a way that most
people like just don't realize
so I wanted to show a quick example
um this is a channel one of the channels
that I manage I've been working with
them for two and a half almost three
years now and when this video first
released uh we got a weapon
109 views now at the time this channel
was I'm pretty sure somewhere in the
round around the 5 000 subscriber Mark
range just to give you some relative
scale and
this particular video we we were
actually super hyped for this video
because uh this was a a very well
produced interview between uh the client
that I work with and Robert Kiyosaki and
we were like super excited to see how
this video would perform and when we
released it we were a little
disappointed uh I believe this one was
uh to Terry's comment in the seven to
eight out of ten range and we were a
little kind of scratching our heads like
what did what in the world went wrong
and sure enough we started we started
running some tests on this just because
um I you know it's like when a when a
video that we are very confident is
going to perform well doesn't perform
well
um you know those are the prime
opportunities to go in and and actually
test uh so around uh we gave it about a
month just to let uh the subscribers
kind of see the video and make sure that
we were looking at a cold audience we
started testing uh toward the end of
August and then ultimately we rolled
into
uh you know a couple weeks into
September and our testing had started to
complete and we noticed an uptick and
the overall viewership and as you can
see kind of how things progressed this
video actually started to perform
extremely well uh we were averaging
around at the peak around just under 6
000 views a day and we were at we were
adding on an extra 100 subscribers so
for a channel that that is you know in
the 5000 subscriber range to go from
basically averaging 10 to 15 subscribers
a day to over 100 subscribers uh that's
that's a that's a big win
um Evan has also uh had an experience
where he's done thumbnail refreshes on
his videos where all of a sudden just as
a function of going back to some of the
older videos and refreshing some of the
thumbnails he's been able to get some of
his videos to perform go from just a
couple hundred views a day to over 15
000 views a day
um this was actually uh for those of you
who are unaware this uh came from a
one-pager that YouTube actually put
together and I believe he's got it on
his his brand Linux sales page uh that
that walks through which video uh he ran
this test on and ultimately which video
started to perform uh you know pretty
well I believe it was one of his uh
uh top 10 on
Oprah so uh lots of lots of really good
opportunities with testing and I just
kind of wanted to show you the power
that by going back and looking at your
older videos you have a clear
opportunity to really move the needle
for your channel and the beautiful thing
about it is at the end of the day
these are videos you don't have like you
don't have to make a new video in order
to get this kind of result you can go
back and make some just some minor
tweaks to older videos and start to see
those videos perform over time and
really move the needle for your Channel
so I wanted to take a little bit of time
to talk about thumbnail best practices
we're all familiar with the thought
leadership layout uh I'm pretty sure
Evan Harps this anytime he talks about
thumbnails it's it's all about the
format how do we how do we replicate the
the big thought leaders in the space and
how do we make our videos stand out and
and really drive home like what it is
somebody's going to ultimately get with
that video he is kind of after all the
tests that he's run I think he's over 10
000 tests uh across his and even in the
test that I've run for my clients I
think I'm I'm in the mere two two or
three thousand tests
um this format time and time again
continues to perform uh and
leverage leverage this format because at
the end of the day it simplifies
everything that you're doing and gives
you the ability to then create systems
around uh your thumbnail process such
that this is an area where you can start
to Outsource uh this activity when your
channel is big enough and you're
starting to move in the direction of uh
testing at scale
so the next thing that I that he talks
about very specifically is is having
high saturation in your videos
I I I was trying to think of how to best
represent this and I I went ahead and
took one of his thumbnails and actually
took the saturation out of the out of
the thumbnail there's a you can actually
in Photoshop you can go and there's a
slider where you can take the saturation
down
would you click on that video
like
who's gonna click on that video nobody's
gonna click on that video so make sure
that you're using colors with high
saturation and and this is this is very
common practice in uh you know website
design when you're really trying to like
create a stark difference uh and and
be very clear as to what it is that
you're trying the call to action that
you're trying to create for somebody at
the end of the day we're we're trying to
have your video stand out you know we
want to have some level of branding so
that people recognize like this is this
is a Evan Carmichael video or this is a
Lewis house video or a Terry Thompson
video we want people to recognize and
start to get a feel for what your videos
look like but we also want to create
um clickability through the saturation
um and and honestly if if you feel like
you've gone
hard enough with the saturation and
you're you're not getting the results
that you're looking for try changing the
color sometimes sometimes Shifting the
color a little bit uh can really move
the needle and uh eek out an extra
couple of percentage points on your on
your tests so at the end of the day uh
as we get into the testing you you want
to try different things and we'll we'll
go through a little bit of what that
looks like in the process the next thing
is to think about who your audience is
and where they're watching you know a
lot of times when we're designing
thumbnails we are in Photoshop full
scale resolution on uh 20 you know 20
plus inch monitor and where you know
everything looks great but when you
shrink it down the questions that I ask
myself are is if there's a face in the
in the video can I identify who that
person is you know if you're a person if
you're dealing with interviews where
you're talking with people full of note
we want to make sure that it's very
clear who who's that video going to be
about
um
or if you're the main focal of your
channel making sure that people
recognize you as a on that thumbnail a
lot of a lot of times people will
do the basically from the waist to the
head as as their uh what's on the right
hand side of the photo
um what we have found in all of our
testing is when you zoom in on the face
that gets the best result from a
click-through rate perspective so it you
want to make sure that you know
I've seen it done both ways where you've
got like super polished pictures as well
as screen caps from the video itself
um I think there's uh times when you can
go either way but at least in our tests
what we have found is that the screen
caps actually perform better uh rather
than if you have like the same thumbnail
or the same pictures that you're using
over and over again over time those will
start to from a click-through rate
perspective they'll start to Decay and
people they'll be less clickable because
people think that it's a similar video
to what was previously released
all right welcome everybody we are
talking about YouTube titles today in
this session I'm super excited this is
really important because you spend so
much time you know making a video that
uh we want to make sure we're picking
the right videos and the ones that can
actually get us some views you know we
spend so much time on the content I know
some of you guys are the actual content
creator and some of you are representing
the content creator you're on the team
of the content creator so the creators
time is always the number one asset and
the hardest thing to get in front of the
camera to actually go and make so
picking good titles is going to make a
really really big difference so don't
focus on search and this is where
uh
what I talk about I guess is a lot
different than most of the YouTube
experts or tools or software uh search
is not the game on YouTube
so most views don't happen from search
most views will happen from what's being
recommended especially as YouTube's
gotten better with the recommendation
engine most of the views of your channel
should be coming from suggested and
browse and suggested is what's showing
up against other videos and browse is
what's showing up typically from
somebody's home page when they're when
they're scrolling through that's where
most views happen
it's not from search
even if you think about your own
experience with search
you might search for something and there
is a lot that's happening in search
right YouTube is the second largest
search engine in the world after Google
so it's not that search is nothing but
what usually happens is people will
search they'll watch one video Whatever
shows up in the search results and then
based on what's being recommended people
don't usually go back to the search page
and search again they'll just dive down
YouTube's recommendations so they watch
one video from search and on the watch
five six seven eight more from what's
being recommended on that same topic
so the ultimate game how the how the
channels are getting millions and
millions subscribers it's not coming
from search for the most part I'll give
get into one exception
um it's coming from the videos that are
being recommended by YouTube so the game
that we want to play if we really want
to turbocharge our YouTube growth is not
showing up in search it's showing up
against the videos that are already
doing well
that becomes the big game and so it's
nothing wrong if search is is a big
component of your traffic it's just
playing the small game you know if 30 of
the views on YouTube come from search
you could try to optimize for that but
why not optimize for where most of the
views are actually coming from so Greg
you know I don't know if you meant
actually you know search for search or
just really trying to figure out how to
get more views on the video but I think
a lot of people think about this like
how do I show up in search it's the
default way and I think a lot of the
tools are training you to think search
first it's just not the big game of how
to actually blow up your YouTube channel
yeah that's exactly why I asked the
question that way
perfect so don't do it
I'll share some examples that's why it's
why we're here so here are some three
examples from different size channels
that I have and this is the past 20 days
this is up to date like I looked at this
last night the past 28 days what
percentage of my traffic comes from
search and you can see it ranges from
seven percent to 15 or 14.9 percent so
that's still significant but it's not
the big game and so you know obviously
my main channel is here but then I tried
to pull
um a smaller Channel just a little more
reachable for you guys search it's just
not the main thing we want to be
optimizing around
uh just here's an example I pulled from
last night you know best entrepreneur
habits the number one video that shows
up has got 8 000 views on it 9 000 views
on it has 240 subscribers or a thousand
subscribers it doesn't matter showing up
for best entrepreneur habits
this this is not this is a this is who
cares like our goal is not so yippee
he's number one for this search term but
he's not getting tons of views on this
video
what it is interesting is you look down
here you see Brian Tracy he's got this
video 4.9 million views with 1 million
subscribers this is a really good video
now it doesn't even have the same
keywords I guess habits is there you
know daily habits of successful people
Brian Tracy but I put a best
entrepreneur habits in
what we should be doing is trying to
figure out how do we show up after a big
video like this
so
um Greg I don't I don't know too much
about your channel yet or what you do
but we can dive in a little bit more you
think about what are the keywords that
you would think about ranking for and
instead of that look at the videos that
are doing well already and the game
becomes how do I rank after them so this
is an exercise I usually go through uh
with somebody new I'd look at for myself
best entrepreneur habits that would that
should align with my channel and what I
talk about maybe not for Greg if he's
doing kind of Outdoors stuff but it
would for me so I really should make a
video called daily habits of successful
people
because my goal would be to rank after
Brian Tracy's video
I could make a video called best
entrepreneur habits but it's not a great
term I could make a video 10 habits of
successful entrepreneurs how to win in
business and life but this video is not
doing super well I want to make the
video called daily habits as successful
people
this is a video that I should make I
should send this to my team and say guys
let's make this video
we might have already done it but that'd
be a good video for my Niche to make
because the game then becomes once
people watch this Brian Tracy video this
is where we want to show up this is
where all the views are coming from
suggested right and if I go back to my
home page then it'd be that would be
browse so when somebody's watching this
most people will not go back they don't
click back on their browser or in their
phone they don't click back to go back
to this page to go back to the search
results they start consuming this and
YouTube's become the master at bringing
up videos that they think you're going
to care about that relate to the topic
so I typed this in the number one video
is a another Brian Tracy speech number
two is Evan Carmichael that's great I'm
happy to see that and then some you know
other videos here uh and so this becomes
our game it's like how people are
watching this video how do I rank
against this video that becomes a big
game for for all of your niches when you
were looking at IQ as a should I use
this this is my favorite feature of vid
IQ is it shows you on the search page
how many subscribers each channel has
so if I typed in the best way to deal
with hate you know as an example
uh you can see some of the videos that
show up and what we want to do is look
for videos that have more views than
subscribers
so this one has Five Sixty thousand
views 1.4 million subscribers so that's
an okay video for them but it's not
fantastic this one 2.2 million views 64
000 subscribers that's a really good
video for them
uh 989 000 views 375 000 subscribers
that's really good video for them so if
I had a channel talking about
dealing with hate like if that fit into
my Niche somehow I would not want to
make a video called dealing with haters
I would want to make a video called how
to ignore people
you suck I don't care
I like that thumbnail
yeah how to ignore people should be a
video that I make and three reasons why
people hate you it could be another
video that I make now these are still
fairly sizable channels I mean for some
of the people in this group that's
that's where they're at and for some of
you you're way smaller than this
um that's totally fine you'll you could
if you keep scrolling down on the page
you'll find people you'll find videos
from channels that maybe have a thousand
subscribers and have 50 000 views it
doesn't have to be 2.2 million views you
know if you have a thousand subscribers
and 50 000 views on a video that's a
really really really good video that's a
breakthrough video so this strategy
scales it works for big channels it
works with small channels the key is
going through what are some keywords
that you think you want to make a video
on and then seeing what people are
actually making videos on
and how can we re-title some of our
videos to work in this or how can we
design something brand new that fits
this theme
so it falls into two camps one is how do
we optimize existing videos you've
already recorded them we've already made
them they're already up there we've
already spent all this time and energy
and editing and all this stuff how do we
optimize our videos better
this is how you do it
if we can re-title one of our old videos
how to ignore people it has a good
chance of doing better now the video
actually has to be about that topic
right like huge caveats you know if
you're if you're titling it something
and then the video has nothing to do
with that theme or it's way off or it's
buried deep inside it's not going to
help you too much because YouTube also
cares about are people watching your
video
so if I caught my video how to ignore
people and it's Greg's outdoor video it
has nothing to do with ignoring people
then it's not going to work right but
how can you better re-title your old
videos and then how can you plan for new
videos that would fit this model to say
okay I'm going to make a new video
called how to ignore people
uh and it might be fun to dive in after
what some examples just so you can you
can see
here's the here is the exception
when you don't want subscribers
there are some channels where the goal
is not subscribers I don't think it's
anybody in this group
your goal is you want subscribers you
want to build a following you want to
build people you can then sell some
stuff to you want to build your brand
you want people watching your next video
in extreme utility channels
that's not the case so the search term I
used here was how to unclog a toilet
and so here are the examples right this
guy got 1.7 million views on how to
unclog a toilet in three different ways
and this guy got 2.7 million views how
to unclog a toilet with hot water and
dish soap DIY save money before calling
a plumber so
you could see they've got massive
amounts of views on these videos with
very few subscribers right 1.7 million
views 17 000 subscribers 2.7 million
views 19 000 subscribers these are
runaway breakthrough videos for these
guys
but their goal is not to get subscribers
you're you're probably not going to
subscribe to how to unclog a toilet
Channel
it's it's pure utility like you might
but it's it's pure utilities like I got
my answer and I'm out
where for most of you you know if if I
watch a negotiation video from Pablo
hopefully I want to see other
negotiation videos I want to continue to
improve myself in in my negotiation I
care about Pablo's next book review on
negotiation right we're trying to get
subscribers so this is this is the
extreme case where
um search really really really really
matters they're only game as search we
want to be showing up number one for how
to unclog a toilet
right and you don't care about
subscribers and some people this is this
is a great business model it's just not
usually For Thought leaders of the
people in this group
um if this is you we can dive deeper
into that but for the most part it's not
all right everybody we are talking about
landing pages lead magnets and getting
people off of YouTube and into your
business for most of the people who I
end up talking to
you have a business and your goal is to
get people from social media from your
YouTube channel to then go and buy your
stuff right the goal isn't just to have
X number of subscribers on YouTube the
goal is to actually grow the business so
that's what having an effective lead
magnet does I'm going to share some
examples of what we have used how we've
shifted our strategy to what we are
using now and sharing some other
examples from uh some of my friends that
I think could be helpful as well so
here's what we used to do so we
we make a lot of videos a day right
we'll release
30 videos a day ish uh across different
channels so it's a lot of content so
what we were initially doing was
making
a bunch of different programs for people
to subscribe to that were free and I
would interrupt my videos
saying hey if you want to get access to
this there's links in the description
so try to make it as customized as
possible so this would be you know a Joe
dispenza top 10 rules
he's sharing his rules great
and then after the fourth rule
I would come on I'd be in my car and say
hey if you we designed this program our
own confidence if you want to get it
click the link below right I'll show you
what it looks like
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief I've
designed a special free training to help
you do it the sign says it can take up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a new habit and I want that for
you I want you to build the habit of
self-belief so what I'm going to do is
email you every day for 254 days a link
to an unlisted video that will shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below so
I'm pitching it we have the links in the
description below always there the arrow
always there for the whole thing I will
record a new version of this every week
so there's some variety so sometimes I'm
here in my studio here I am in my car my
wife is
doing some shopping
and I'm filming my next thing these work
surprisingly well like the you in your
regular life work pretty well and then
it's not just the exact same video every
time so if somebody has seen your videos
before they still are incentivized to do
it
um
so I used to only do it fancy here in my
office but these have worked out this is
just me on my iPhone with with airpods
while she's shopping I'm pressing record
I have a little uh tripod or like a
handheld little tripod in my hand and go
you know the the uh you know I mean the
car is decent but the the background
isn't anything fancy just get a little
bit of sun on your face there's some
like shipping company or something right
it's not it's not like I'm walking on
the beach or in Malibu or at the top of
some mountain or in some fancy hotel
um
and it just creates the connection to
you and it forms a little bit of a
pattern interrupt from watching the
video
right so if it's if it's your own video
and it you can't logically find a way to
tie it into the content then you want to
interrupt yourself with a pre-recorded
version of it
in the middle of every video so what Dan
was doing was he's talking about the
things here are the nine habits
and if you want these slides there's a
link below so it fits perfectly for the
video that he's doing
sometimes it may not fit perfectly so
you interrupt yourself and put an ad in
the middle so this is after rule four
right this is a you know it's an hour
long video we're doing it here at uh at
the 10 minute Mark so we'll throw a
whole bunch of bonuses at the end but
there's 10 rules this is that the rule
four we throw in this and then we'll do
a highlight or preview of what you're
going to get so what I'm promising them
is 254 days of videos that are going to
be emailed to them for free
and then there's going to be a preview
of what they're getting against how to
know what this Market but I think and
then back to the content
so
pitch me what I'm gonna get
show me what I'm gonna get
and then the link is in the description
and the more that you can show that on
screen
right
like Link in the description Arrow I'm
going to point down there go check that
out
then watch more likely to do it
if you as the host are calling that out
they're much more likely to do it and
then here this should be higher like
this is
we have four different lead magnets here
they can sign up for but one of these
should be higher above above the fold
so that's what we were doing and where
that would go
um if we looked at
this or this they should just go to
landing pages this would be the 254 days
this is what I talked about in the video
and then they can go sign up for here
and it just leads to a pop-up where they
can we can get in
and then this is the 30-day program
where
name an email
uh and then we're gonna show like some
videos this is standard landing page
stuff you know what am I going to get
easy sign up show some videos of people
saying how great it is show some uh
credibility like who is this guy
and then some examples of what you're
going to get on different days and then
just comments again of how much people
really enjoyed it
um and then again sign up again and you
know back to testimonials and bonuses
and little pictures to show example
right and this is you know six figures
of email signups
some people going through the stuff
right so you set up the landing page
once we did a bunch of split tests on it
um now you can see like the the number
at the at the top best life and then a
whole bunch of numbers we've played
around with different variations and
this was the one that converted the best
uh right but this is standard kind of
landing page stuff but just to get a
sense of what I'm gonna get when I land
on the page and then once once you're in
your email system you can you can help
them with whatever else your programs
your coaching your paid programs your
books your Consulting you know whatever
the next step is for them
uh the other thing I did when I was in
book promotion mode was I
featured people who talked about my book
so I scheduled a bunch of interviews
with people I asked when I asked Brendan
Bouchard hey Brandon what's the number
one thing you did to promote your book
he said I had people read my book
so I had Larry King read my book and he
gave them like two sentences from the
book and they read it on camera and then
he used that as a demo reel of all these
famous people all his friends reading
the book so I said that's a cool idea
will you do it
and so he he read a couple lines from my
book and so I did a lot of
collaborations with people around the
book
um this was a live that I did with Grant
uh I popped on his live and he he's what
did he say
and you got a book coming out don't you
and then we started talking about my
book uh you just came out
where can people get it
get it on Amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there let's go man if you
guys don't know Evan Evan Carmichael
he's got a new book out Builder sir go
grab it today at Amazon
there's a good dude right here
okay so that's in the middle of a video
right
so same thing
this would be this is a video we did on
Grant after the fourth rule we interrupt
it it's it's Grant
and me talking about the book this was a
much longer clip but you know we want we
don't want to sit through
minutes of me and Grant talking because
they're signing up for you know they're
watching Grant on the video right now uh
but here check the link in description
to get your copy he's talking about it
so if you have any friends who are
willing to read it they don't have to be
as you know high up as Grant Cardone but
can you integrate that into your content
somehow again I was in book promo mode I
wanted to get people off of
YouTube and into buying my book
and so we with intention featured a lot
more content of my friends who are
willing to read the book
so for
uh you know 30 days we had 20 something
people either read the book or do some
kind of collab with this like Grant
didn't actually read the book probably I
mean he didn't he didn't read a line
from the book like I would for Brendan
and other people
um
but for 20 20 something days we feature
different people who had read the book
and then we incorporated this this clip
into it this isn't a lead magnet this is
gonna go to
here check out Evan's new book first
line
Evan carmichael.com book and that I
think goes to Amazon
yeah that'll go to Amazon but you still
have it as your own link because you can
redirect that to something else if you
want
right if you actually made this the
Amazon link then I'd have to if any if I
ever wanted to change it to something
else
then I'd have to go up and update all of
the videos versus making it your own
website that you can then forward
so this was the second version of it not
a lead magnet but getting people to take
action on something and still Evergreen
like the biggest advantage of YouTube
again is that this content will live
forever
but my book will live forever so I'm
happy with that gotten more attention
towards a buck but I'm again purposely
interrupting my video
to try to get someone to take action
if you want to see this full video as
well as trained live with me twice a
month to blow up your brand join the
brand Linux training program there's a
link to join right there next to me you
can to believe